hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to another indie horror game
this one called wooden floor because
nothing is more terrifying than
remodeling your home or something like
that I actually don't know a lot about
this game but I'm gonna find out now I
know that it's about wooden floors of
some sort you're in a log cabin and that
guy in the painting was giving you an
awfully intense stare I think he might
be into you guys oh look I might be
waking from a drunken stupor this would
be a delightful start to any day
especially my own and there's no one in
my bed so I'm just gonna be here alone
goody goody goody gumdrops Russ either
use or manipulate an object well ok then
I have a book
ditto I'm just picking up I thought that
might have gone in my inventory or
something but apparently not can I let
that go please thank you this game is
actually made on the Unity engine as
opposed to some of the games that I've
played there were no it's not only unity
and it's on the Unreal development kit
which means that it's some slightly
better technology than the older Unity
engines but actually I've been proven
wrong the Unity oh hello mr. P are you
gonna guide me to from place to place
hello are you for you yes indeed you are
but one second hello nothing in there
nothing at all good good I wouldn't make
that want to make this too easy on me
so oh hello oh you okay thank you for
that friendly advice I really appreciate
it I really appreciated any ghosts in
this house good glad I could make that
announcement anyway back to this strange
painting you seem slightly disturbed in
what's going on here although you're
staring up as opposed to that actually I
shouldn't stare at paintings in general
that's a bad luck for me in the past so
I'm just gonna move on here oh good the
horror music's started it's awfully dark
in here did I get a flashlight or
something I don't actually have anything
else to help me so there may be more
behind a shut door than just another
wooden floor that's a very good rhyme
you should write poetry
those beautiful in every way elegant
even and where the hell am I going does
not move that's good for it why does it
not move does not move does anything
move in this
does anything but pin groove not bump
and groove but bump and groove is what I
meant to say so oh hello thank you
conveniently placed illumination is
there something here unlocked oh well
hello so I should shut all the doors
behind me who saw that intense message
told me hello
Oh uses a skull okay anything over here
something a book well oh hi I didn't
even notice that at first I wasn't sure
what happened
are you comfortable up there you want
anything else okay I'll just go on my
way then please visit me again oh is
this gonna be one of those games where
every time I close the door and I reopen
it's gonna be different
ah nothing different in here gosh it is
dark the blacks in this game and the
shadows are very very intense so it's
hard to see what's in the darkness ah it
is one of these games I love these type
of games that change everything
cool cool cool cool nothing in the
drawer over there but something is
different about this cupboard ooh I like
it already
I like it very much so I can't wait to
get thank you thank you for that wasn't
there supposed to be like a kool-aid man
that was bursting through there saying
maybe
oh yes or something along those lines I
don't know is there something in there
that I need hello darkness hello
darkness my old friend I've come to see
you again
alright wait a minute was that door
always there or did I just turn around
for a second day to change stuff on me
maybe maybe not but I'm gonna find out
hello Thank You illumination of
lightning very convenient for you to be
there for me so now I need to go over
here and see what's oh hello I heard
that over there you can't fool me
I heard you okay maybe you were over
there I'm not sure what's Rickson I was
supposed to look did you sometimes feel
like going the wrong way all of the time
my name is markiplier and if you did not
know I do that a lot I don't go
the game actually knowing what I'm going
to do oh oh I like this very much
let me always close it does not move but
you told me you gave me a very important
lesson that I was supposed to
hello phantasm oh hi
are you still there in the darkness are
you about to kill a okay
my camera is moving slightly that was
weird
cool I saw a phantasm or a ghost tegu as
the technical name for it is alright
anyway so that was something that was
great what that happened there what now
I'm gonna move on and never experience
it ever again this game sure is slow
pace on the jump scares that kind of
like that actually is that a door or am
I just twiddling my dongers here oh good
not only did that chair fall but
everything has been nailed to the
ceiling that's gonna be very
inconvenient for things in the future
I wonder what's going on in this room is
it a note up there hello what do you say
how did I get up here very good question
how can I open anything else in here so
something that I need I can't see
anything it is literally pitch-black in
the shadows okie dokie wait a minute
what the you are not that big before
that's what she said but also you
weren't that big before this is open is
that something is any of this something
what the hell is going on here
everything seems to be changing on me
and I don't much appreciate it but in
reality it very much appreciated because
it makes things much much much more
interesting God but it is so dark okay
what have you got for me game bring it
what oh excuse me okay my brain is
my brain is melting out my ears what's
going on here
do you like my books um whoa what have
you written the book said I picked up or
the books that fell from the ceiling
because I don't know which one I'm
supposed to like is this a door I can
open it is locked so I need to find
another key oh where oh where could
another key be that does not move so I'm
hoping that things have changed back
from whence I came the ambience in this
game is good I kind of do like the slow
pacing of it it's messing with me but in
very short increments I don't think that
there's a save system so has something
changed in here maybe I need to close it
oh no wait it didn't move did it oh no
that did move okay so if I close that
and I try to open it again maybe I'll
try to find something else going on here
hello ah nothing changed you were
supposed to change bro okay maybe I'll
go back the way I came not exactly sure
what I'm supposed to be expected of here
am I supposed to do something or am I
just kind of along for the ride maybe if
I closed oh this one does not move well
I guess I can't go back the way I came
because it's not going anywhere do you
feel sometimes like going the wrong way
uh yes exactly like that how about right
now then that thought is kind of
crossing my mind here it's been a long
December and there's reason to believe
that I may not find the exit to this
game maybe someday I will wander through
the door and then I will get to where I
am supposed to be please don't sue me
Counting Crows because I don't know your
song and I hope that you will not be
listening to this video hello ah I found
my marbles that's good do I do anything
about that do I do anything about that
come on you have to let me do something
about that those conveniently placed
balls that fell on my face there's got
to be something for that please fine mmm
oh-oh-oh I randomly went up to a
painting and I clicked to use key and it
worked I got a key somehow I don't know
how that worked but I did and that's all
that matters in this game so thank you
so much thank you so much random
painting person oh it doesn't open
although I don't think that door open oh
okay
what are you doing okay cool that's
great but why why is that that sir okay
that's good that's good for you are
those gonna be monsters that's right
okay good great great I've already got
the heebie jeebies please don't chill my
spine any more than it needs to be
children dead body how about this one is
there a dead body in here ooh
did you ever hide yourself in a wardrobe
well I have many times I'll do it again
oh well I guess it okay
do I need to hide is hiding a necessary
skill to my survival so it's like the
prestige and I just Cologne myself and
the other me is trapped in there or
drowned in a tank by the way if you
haven't seen prestige you'll see that
movie is very good and very disturbing
much like this game why is that covered
okay why did that go out I do not like
this Sam I am I do not like this even a
little bit hello Frederick Don Duchenne
heimer have you won many wars is this my
bed am I supposed to go to sleep do I
like it what is that I have a book I
think I have a book good who's anyone
like to read my book should I take in
the app mmm maybe I won't I have no idea
what's going on in this game what do I
do
I don't know I'm utterly confused I hope
there wasn't something that I was
supposed to retrieve from that I need a
key good what am I supposed to find one
of those why was there Trey put over
that painting this is something that is
okay good I found a key I was wondering
if I was gonna randomly press the use
button if I could spit any mores would
be delightful thank you
where am I going what am i doing where
am i what happened what happened it just
got dark oh okay well good this is
exactly what I wanted to do with my life
where am I going now okay I fell oh good
there was a slightly unenumerated piece
of wood that I was supposed to cross
across good for me thank you so much for
being a giant doucher now if you could
only give me the other side of the log
so I could actually walk across it where
is it
is it here it's in the darkness that I
cannot see my eyes cannot even perceive
the greatness of the wood that is in
front of me is this why it's called
wooden floor because reasons and also
because I need to take a leap of faith
oh come here
come on you [ __ ] I'm gonna getcha I'm
gonna ride on top of you you're gonna
take me exactly where I need to go and
no frankly ghosty goo I do not like the
books that you are selling me that was
not what I made it dammit you and your
douchiness goddamnit there was a log
there stop telling me there aren't logs
when there are logs stop making me drop
off I can't exactly scream right now
I've got my microphone set hi I do not
want to yell directly and plead the ears
of my audience they're very nice people
Dana why do I not have a flashlight of
any type that would be extremely helpful
to my situation in this area because I
can't see what you're doing to me where
is the wooden plank if you could come
out of the darkness for just two seconds
maybe I could actually there you go
thank you for not being a giant a-hole
I'm trying to be family-friendly here
but not really because [ __ ] not her
douche okay so there are chairs here
that I was actually supposed to step on
hi I was mistaken in my Union is girl
okay so if you're there this is going to
turn in that's gonna get flat and you're
about to get flat oh yes I am the winner
I'm the winner of everything I have won
all the awards okay so oh did I just
fall in a hole did I just fall in a hole
hello oh hi hi there if you could um
take my candle oh thank you this is very
helpful except that it's not very
helpful
ooh you are a beautiful lady are your
legs also arms because that's very
convenient for my uses not that I'm
strange or anything not that you need to
be concerned of why I need your arms to
be legs but just
don't look into it all that much okay
can I say that this candle is actually
less helpful than not having the candle
and why am i walking into these darkness
oh no no that was actually really good
besides a few points of it being too
dark that was actually very very good oh
man that was actually a lot of fun guys
I I made the commentary a little bit
different in this episode if you notice
that I wasn't speaking as raucously as I
usually do because my voice is a little
bit sore I've been recording a lot of
episodes in a sequence here so either
way I hope you enjoyed it it's a little
bit different than it should be or maybe
it won't be different at all maybe you
guys didn't even notice and you thought
it was better so thank you all so much
for watching if you enjoyed this
there'll be a link in the description to
the website or the development page of
this game I was actually really cool the
changing up of things was very
interesting although I think it didn't
push the horror aspect enough it could
have been a little more engaging than it
was but either way it was really cool
just wish I could have seen what was
going on so thank you all so much for
watching check the description for more
horror games that I've done click the
annotation for more horror games that
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video bye bye
what that's why you're worried if
they're not